and how has it been received now because
i'm sure it was so different back in
1986 with these cameras and even the
ernest borg nine years
but now everyone's doing it you've got
nine-year-olds with their iphones so how
is it now to compete with that it's
terrible
you know it's it's no i'm kidding i mean
i i i say bring i i'm very excited when
i see really talented people doing
really interesting and talented things
and you know i
you know it really kind of helps spur
you on
you know to you know and you want to i'm
always asking if i see somebody you know
i'll write some somebody and ask how'd
you do that and i'm curious you know a
lot of it is you know the cameras are
getting better and better i mean look
this camera's not even a video camera
you know you're working in um
you know it's an slr you know
canon that has a microphone on top but
it wasn't originally i'm still working
in tape how crazy is that i didn't
really i haven't made the leap uh
to a chip i mean my my iphone will make
video i've shot with that and uh but
just i i still
have my camera goes to tape although i
i'm not churning out as much stuff as i
i was but um i believe in the new
technology and i'm
i think it's clearly
um more economical it makes more sense
but you know hard drives
you know are smaller
to store things on store it on
you know you don't need as much uh
it doesn't take up as much of a
footprint but i think as far as the
content
that's out there
like like i would love to have a video a
youtube channel that would get a zillion
hits or that would possibly make me
money but i can't compete with some of
this other stuff
i'm being realistic because i don't have
the juice that some of these other
people have and i think that's
that's okay because it's a lot of it's a
kind of a young person's universe in
that sense and um
i think if people can still kind of come
to what i do through other means
you know i i i don't mean a young person
and that's not to say it's bad it's just
that and i i would love to be on that
playing field but i think like i'm not
you know i'm not hardwired in some
respects that i think that
people are
that maybe have grown up with um
like gaming i didn't i missed the whole
gaming
thing and
yeah and then
i mean when i was in school you know
computers were punch cards so it's still
you know this is just where but i really
believe you have to adapt or die and so
i try to keep up with what's happening
and i see
i see you know who are the hot online um
video providers
and uh you know try to emulate them to
some degree but i also know that you
have to really turn it out regularly
if you're going to build up any
audience and i just
i'm not doing that it's a lot of work
it's a lot of work i don't have that i i
mean i'm happy i just it's fine i mean
i'm happy with what i have and i just
whatever i put something out i can
you know celebrate that
you